this is alexei navalny's latest
investigation from the siberian city of
tomsk released today
an expose of pervasive corruption which
he ties to local deputies of the ruling
party
if i started traveling to russian cities
calling for a war on united russia he
says
this place would be first on the list
the next day
he was poisoned the german government
says by a military-grade nerve agent
from the novichok family
attempts to sabotage united russia are
not looked unkindly
though putin's grievances against his
foremost critic
date back more than a decade and
navalny's team are convinced that the
kremlin is responsible
the fact that it was novichok like
putin's
signature poison like leaving the
business card of mr putin on the crime
scene
it was kind of it was quite a shock for
us
the kremlin says there are no grounds
for accusing moscow
the key suspect in alexander
litvinenko's poisoning andre lugovoy
telling sky news he saw no reason for
russia to poison him
i don't understand which motivation
russia should have
first of all the pilot who landed plane
in time secondly the doctors who saved
his life
and russia itself gave him to the
germans it was them who found out he was
poisoned
anastasia vasilieva is a close friend
and associate of navalny's
she says he wouldn't be alive if it
weren't for the emergency landing in
omsk
if pilots
did not landed in omsk and if maybe
medical workers in ambulance didn't
treat him
in a similar way to the
poisoning so of course he could die
the uk european and nato leaders are
mulling their response
but if moscow had cared about the
consequences then alexei navalny would
not be lying in a coma in a german
hospital
his body fighting off the effects of a
nerve agent attack